ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute geht es um eine Einführung in das
forschungsmanagement ich mache einen
Link zu den vergangenen Sitzung oben
rechts rein da ging es um die Frage wie
wir in der Didaktik angemessen der
Wissenschaft interagieren und wie wir
auch forschungskommunikation
Wissenschaftskommunikation betreiben
heute soll aber das Thema
forschungsmanagement im Zentrum stehen
und wir haben ein Programm ich gebe
zunächst einen Rückblick auf
wissenschaftliche Kommunikations und
transferprojekte dann aber soll speziell
das tagungsprojekt im Zentrum stehen
warum tagungsprojekte sind Paradigmen
sind rote Fäden
entlang deren wir besonders gut
wissenschaftliche Kommunikation erlernen
und praktizieren können
Kommunikationsprojekte als
tagungsprojekte haben natürlich auch was
mit publikationsprojekt zu tun aus
tagungsprojekten ergeben sich häufig
auch Publikationen z.B durch
tagungswände das wiederum wirft die
Frage auf wie wir Tagungen und auch
publikationsprojekte finanzieren hier
müssen wir Anträge schreiben für
forderwerke Förderwerke Z nächsten
Rückblick
Kommunikationsprojekte was ist das Ziel
wir sehen dass es darauf
ankommt zu definieren was eigentlich
unser Ziel ist das ist vielen gar nicht
ganz klar und deswegen scheitern auch
häufig Projekte in gerade auch in der
Wissenschaft welche Forschungsinhalte
will ich vermitteln das ist eine Frage
weitere Frage ist was ist mein Publikum
meine Zielgruppe an wen richtet sich das
man muss sich vorstellen ein
Forschungsprojekt ist immer ein
kommunikationsprojekt das immer immer
ein Adressat oder eine Adressatin hat um
diese Botschaft und diese
Wissenschaftskommunikation auch in der
Forschung konkret am Beisel von Tagen
realisieren zu können müssen wir auch
immer ein geeignetes Medium wählen über
das wir diese Botschaften austauschen
und von der Wahl des Mediums hängt
entscheidend davon ab ob diese
Kommunikation in der Wissenschaft
speziell gelingt oder scheitert
wir sollten auch nie vergessen dass sich
Kommunikation gerade auch in der
Wissenschaft in Raum und Zeit vollzieht
das bedeutet wir müssen reflektieren auf
diese Bedingungen die dieser
Kommunikation zu Grunde liegen und diese
Bedingungen sind eben immer räumlich und
zeitlich und oft werden sie vergessen
weit es ja nur auf Inhalt fokussiert
wird aber eben nicht auf diese Formen
die wie auch das Medium wesentlich dazu
beitragen ob die Kommunikation ob
wissenschaftliche Praxis gelingt oder
scheitert das sind also so diese
Rahmenbedingung die wir uns
vergegenwertigen sollten und jetzt
behandeln wir mal diese Frage nach
forschungsmanagement und
Wissenschaftskommunikation konkret auch
am Beispiel von
tagungsprojekten ich habe schon gesagt
wissenschaftliche Tagung eignet sich
hervorragend dafür verschiedene
Funktionen verschiedene Aufgaben in der
Wissenschaft gerade auch in der
Kommunikation abzudecken
warum sie erlauben zum einen die
Vernetzung mit anderen Forscherinnen und
Forschern daraus ergeben sich wiederum
weitere Kooperation und Projekte das
heißt Tagungen sind auch Form von
Multiplikatoren
multiplikationsprojekte Katalysatoren
sie ermöglichen neue Entwicklungen wenn
sie richtig konzipiert sind und sie
erlauben auch Publikation z.B durch
Tagungsbände wir hatten uns schon
befasst mit den Prinzipien von Didaktik
und wissenschaftstransfer und auf diesen
Prinzipien basieren letztendlich auch
wissenschaftliche
Forschungsmethoden und wissenschaftliche
Tagungen wenn ich jetzt eine
wissenschaftliche Tagung organisieren
möchte dann stellt sich die Frage nach
dem geeigneten Thema eine Tagung muss
ein Thema ein Gegenstand zum Thema haben
das auch als ein Problem angesehen
werden kann also eine Tagung kann sich
auch mit einer Frage befassen dieses
Thema sollte jetzt nicht zu weit gefasst
sein aber auch nicht zu eng es kommt
also auf diesen richtigen Mittelweg
zwischen diesen Extremen an ein weiterer
Punkt eine weitere Dimension die
tagungsprojekte erfolgreich erscheinen
lässt ist die Relevanz und auch die
Aktualität eine Tagung profitiert auch
wesentlich davon dass sie geeignete
Referentin und Referenten hat hier kann
man persönliche Kontakte und
Empfehlungen nutzen Tagungen sind
Ereignis in Raum und Zeit wie ich schon
sagte wir müssen Raum und Zeit als
Formen gelingender wissenschaftlicher
Praxis immer mit berücksichtigen und wir
müssen natürlich auch finanzielle
Rahmenbedingungen klären Wissenschaft
vollzieht sich nicht n im elfenbein
Wissenschaft ist am Ende auch eine Frage
der Förderung das ist jetzt aber nicht
nur aus ökonomischen Gründen wichtig
sondern häufig ist eine Förderung einer
Tagung auch ein Indiz dafür dass diese
Tagung
wissenschaftlich korrekt und
konkurrenzfähig konzipiert wurde man
sollte es nicht immer als direktes
Zeichen werden aber die heutige
wissenschaftssituation ist so dass sie
wesentlich auf Konkurrenz passiert und
hier kann man sehr viel lernen wenn man
sich durchsetzt gegen anderen gegenüber
anderen aussichtsreichen Anträgen eine
Tagung kann man dann auch kommunizieren
man muss sie ankündigen über
verschiedene Kanäle und Medien auch hier
ist wiederum das geeignete Medium sehr
wichtig und die Tagung muss auch
durchgeführt werden gehen wir zunächst
zum Thema Relevanz und Aktualität was
kann das sein es kann z.B ein Jubiläum
sein Jahr
2024 300 geburtstag des Philosophen
Immanuel Kant warum nicht mal ihn auf
seine Aktualität befragen seine
Philosophie weiter kann man sich fragen
an welche
Forschungsergebnisse kann ich anknüpfen
wenn ich jetzt ein bestimmtes Thema für
die Tagung wähle mit wem kann ich
kooperieren wie kann ich kooperieren in
der Hochschule an meinem Standort
hochschulübergreifen regional
überregional national oder sogar
international das ist eine Frage eine
weitere Frage ist kann ich auch
interdisziplinär arbeiten also kann ich
über den Tellerand hinaus bicken wie
trägt das Thema zur Profilierung meiner
bisherigen Forschung bei wie knüpft es
an bisherige Forschungen an kann ich
dazu mein Forschungsprofil erweitern
also es dürfen durchaus auch subjektive
Gründe eine Rolle
spielen Referentin und Referenten sind
ein wichtiger Bestandteil davon lebt
eine Tagung und hier möchte ich ein
Argument bringen ein Punkt machen für
Diversität in der Zusammensetzung von
Referentin Referenten man muss zwischen
Seniorität juniorität so nennt man das
unterscheiden also bekannte Person und
weniger bekannte Person sollten sich in
etwa die Waage halten ausgewiesen
ExpertInnen kann man einladen aber eine
Tagung sollte wenn sie wirklich
fruchtbar ist nicht nur daraus bestehen
weil es sonst auch zu einseitig werden
kann häufig kennen sich diese Personen
schon und man dreht sich im Kreis in
eine Art von Blase nichts Neues wird
mehr argumentiert deswegen lohnt es sich
aus dieser Blase auszubrechen und auch
weiter auf Diversität zu achten
männliche weibliche Beteiligung sollte
ungefähr gleich
sein die Kontaktaufnahme mit Referentin
Referenten hat viele Vorteile ich kann
nämlich schon
vortagungsbeginn Kontakte knüpfen ein
Anschreiben an mögliche Referentin
Referenten ist wichtig es sollte sehr
individuell gehalten sein es sollte
zeigen dass man ganz bewusst sich an
diese jeweilige Person als Referent oder
Referentin wendet das kann bedeuten dass
man auf ihre Forschung Bezug nimmt und
ein Verbindung zum Tagungsthema
herstellt Raum und Zeit hatte ich schon
gesagt sind wichtige Koordinaten eine
Tagung sollte rechtzeitig geplant werden
sie soll sollte aber dann auch
verschiedene Teilschritte beinhalten die
mit der ersten Konzeption beginnen dann
aber auch weiter reichen hin zum genauen
Programm aber auch hin zu der
Finanzierung und zu den Details die dann
die Reservierung von Hotels und
Räumlichkeiten
betreffen ein Raum muss immer auch schon
bald organisiert werden das sollte
möglichst zentral sein zentral zu unter
Kunft zentral zum Restaurant wo man
vielleicht abends noch gemeinsam ist das
ist ganz wichtig besonders wichtig wie
ich schon sagte ist die tagungsförderung
die man beantragen kann nicht muss aber
kann wenn keine sonstitigge Mittel zur
Verfügung stehen falls keine Mittel zur
Verfügung stehen kann man versuchen eine
Tagung über ein Call for Papers zu
realisieren das ist eine Ausschreibung
auf die sich vorüber vor allem
Nachwuchswissenschaftler bewerben die
dann aber auch selbst für Reise und
Unterkunftskosten aufkommen müssen der
Nachteil ist natürlich dass man dadurch
keine Seniorität erhält s eben vor allem
Nachwuchs ein ker papers ist also eine
Ausschreibung die über verschiedene
Kanäle verteilt wird die eingehenden
Beiträge auf deren Basis dann
entschieden wird wer eingeladen wird die
kann man idealerweise auch anonym
begutachten sass man sich nicht von dem
Namen der dem Verhältnis zu diesen
jeweiligen Personen leiten lässt sonder
nur von der Einschlägigkeit Qualität und
Relevanz des vorgeschlagenen Themas das
bedeutet natürlich einen gewissen
selektionsaufwand aber so kann man sich
das Programm auch dann sehr gut
thematisch
zusammenstellen die Ankündigung der
Tagung sobald sie fertig konzipiert ist
ist wichtig Raum und Zeit müssen stehen
und man kann das auf verschiedene Weise
machen Plakate Aushänge aber auch
Rundmails digitale Verteiler Listen und
Homepages das ist sehr zu empfehlen aber
auch weitere zentrale Personen die gut
vernetzt sind und als Multiplikatoren
dienen können hier ist das Beispiel von
einer Tagungshomepage die jetzt eine
digitale virtuelle Tagung zum Gegenstand
hatte hier sieht man in dem Menü ist ein
Anmeldeformular
über das man sich anmelden kann das
heißt die tagungsankündigung referiert
auf die Tagungshomepage die immer
aktuell gehalten ist auf der sich die
definitive Information befinden für den
Fall dass es kurzfristige Änderungen z.B
aufgrund von Erkrankung von Referenten
kommen sollte hier ist aber auch der
Kfer papers noch mal drauf und der
Kontakt hier ganz wichtig Tagungen
sollten immer durch erkenntnisleitende
Fragestellungen bestimmt sein und hier
sind ist so eine ganze Liste dieser
Fragen
aufgelistet ein weiteres Beispiel für
eine mögliche Tagung ist Relevanz
Aktualität diese Tagung ist im Jahr 2 17
veranstaltet worden dem Lutherjahr wo
eben auch ein dialogisches Gespräch
zwischen Luther und Erasmus von
Rotterdam im Zentrum stand auch aktuelle
Themen eignen sich sehr gut für Tagungen
wenn sie z.B es mit Jubiläen zu tun
haben das bietet immer die Möglichkeit
historische Themen und Position auch auf
aktuelle Fragestellung zu vertragen man
kann das ganze dann auch idealerweise im
größeren Kontext veranst ten man kann
versuchen das ganze noch auszustrahlen
indem man versucht einen Sender
wie in diesem Fall alid Alpha dafür zu
gewinnen wichtig ist bei der
Durchführung von Tagungen dass man sich
Unterstützung holt und zwar Hilfskräfte
alerweise ein bis zwe die für alle Fälle
da sind wenn es Pannen gibt gerade auch
in technischer Hinsicht
die Technik muss stimmen Laptops Beamer
Mikrofon dann genügt natürlich eine
Generalprobe nicht da muss man
sehr viel üben das ist sehr wichtig ähm
aber auch genug Pausen sollten
eingeplant werden das ist also sehr sehr
wichtig ähm Verpflegung ist nicht zu
vernachlässigen Kaffee vor allem man
muss bedenken viele der Referentin
Referenten sind früh angereist es ist
anstrengend die kognitive Aufmerksamkeit
lässt nach da kann Kaffee eben auch ein
wichtiges Hilfsmittel sein und kleinere
verpflegungsmittel hingegen sollte man
nicht zu viel Verpflegung bereitstellen
weil das sonst von den tausen und ihren
guten Möglichkeiten der Kommunikation
ablenkt viele Inhalte von Tagung werden
gerade in den Pausen relevant wenn man
sich getraut Fragen zu stellen die man
vielleicht im direkten Anschluss an den
Vortrag nicht stellen wollte dieses
informelle in den Pausen ist auch ein
essenzieller Teil von Tagung und dafür
sollte genug Raum zur Verfügung stehen
der nicht durch Verpflegung überdeck wir
Abendessen sollte man auch immer
einplanen das ist eine Art von
Honorierung weil ja in der Regel keine
Honorare auch bezahlt werden wichtig ist
auch dass man die Tagung möglichst
dokumentiert so dass sie nicht ein
einmaliges Ereignis war das einfach huft
man kann das durch Aufzeichnung machen
wenn man natürlich vorher die
Einwilligung der Referentin Referenten
einholt man kann es aber auch über
publikationsprojekte tun wie z.B
tagungsbändetag Akten hier ist wiederum
die Frage nach einem geeigneten Verlag
sehr wichtig das wiederum führt zur
Frage nach Druckkosten
da hängen also ganz viele anderen
Planungen mit zusammen kommen wir noch
mal auf Förderanträge und Förderwerke zu
sprechen ganz wichtig ist hier die
Passung also welches Förderwerk passt am
besten zu meinem Thema zu meinem Antrag
wir gibt es eine große Anzahl von
Förderinstitutionen und grundsätzlich
gilt je besser die Passung desto höher
die Chance auf Förderungen muss
berücksichtigen dass man sich hier in
einem
Konkurrenzverhältnis zu anderen
antragstellenden befindet und die besten
Chancen eben durch die beste Passung
erreicht weitere Kriterien sind ich
hatte es schon genannt Aktualität
Relevanz aber eben auch
Interdisziplinarität und auch
Internationalität Bezug auf besondere
Anlässe lohnt sich eben auch es gibt
unzählige auch teilweise private
Förderwerke von den man häufig nichts
weiß Stiftungen und so weiter um sich
hier zu orientieren gibt es
hilfreicherweise Datenbanken nationale
internationale österreichisch die
Agentur Verbildung und
Internationalisierung international die
europäische Kooperation teilweise auch
bei Bundesländern wie z.B Bayern da gibt
es gute Suchmaschinen und so kann man
sehr gut suchen was am besten passt hier
sieht man jetzt verschiedene
Suchmaschinen man muss immer nach
Fachbereich schauen und dann kann man
weiter spezifizieren und hier enthält
man dann einige Einträge hier ist so mal
ein Teil der 51 Einträge aufgelistet wo
man natürlich dann im Detail noch mal
genauer nachschauen muss grundsätzlich
gilt die höher die Ebene der Förderung
international umso besser europäische
Förderung stehen über nationalen und
regionalen
Förderungen so viiel zum Thema auch der
Gewichtung der Förderarten hier haben
wir jetzt die Fritz tüssenstiftung die
auch sehr bekannt ist für ihre
tagungsförderung kleinere
wissenschaftliche Tagung werden hier
gefördert es gibt verschiedene Kriterien
die berücksichtigt werden müssen
hier gibt es die Voraussetzung die sind
hier aufgelistet das heißt die Tagung
sollte aus nicht mehr als 20 Personen
bestehen also keine großen Kongresse
hier ist ein Vorschlag zur Gliederung
des Antrags und der ist sehr hilfreich
weil man sich auch bei anderen
Förderinstitution hier gut dran
orientieren kann das bedeutet man sollte
die wissenschaftliche Zielsetzung klar
darlegen aber auch ein Programm und
Zeitplan und auch eine Aufschlüsselung
der Kosten beifügen das hilft einfach um
sich zu orientieren erkenntniszählen
hatte ich schon gesagt ist sehr wichtig
man kann auch manchmal auf eine
Forschungslücke Hinweisen inwiefern ist
die Tagung überhaupt notwendig gibt es
andere Forschungen die diese Tagung
gerade zuu
bedürfen ein Zeitplan Finanzplan hatte
ich schon genannt Kostenart muss man
auch unterscheiden Fahrtkosten
Hotelkosten Verpflegungskosten häufig
werden Honorare nicht übernommen das ist
in der Wissenschaft nicht üblich anders
in ökonomischen Kontexten ja das war ein
kleiner Einblick in die verschiedenen
Herausforderung des
forschungsmanagements diskutiert am
konkreten Beispiel von
wissenschaftlichen
Tagungen